merci à vous me remettez finalement en
cause de problèmes du délégué syndical
et de son élection puisqu'en fait
aujourd'hui dénommé ba par l'extérieur
et je pense qu'effectivement il faut que
ce soit et c'est tous des propositions
aller vers des délégués syndicaux s'il
doit y en avoir qui sont à l'intérieur
de l'entreprise et qui sont élus à ce
moment là pour être pour l'être la
preuve de la prédominance de
l'entreprise sur la branche paraît aussi
un point tout à fait essentiel quant au
rôle du juge bien ce sera la troisième
table ronde qui sera développée tout à
l'heure par eric woerth
je passe la la la la parole à sébastien
pilar donc qu'il ya secrétaire général
du comité d'entrepreneurs des
républicains et un point qu'on avait
encore pas commencé à aborder qui me
paraît fou temps très important c'est le
temps de travail
absolument je vais rebondir sur le sur
les logs sociale qui me semble être un
un sujet fondamental et je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec vous en
disant que le dialogue social
aujourd'hui doit se situer dans
l'entreprise et pas forcément au niveau
des branches et au niveau des structures
interprofessionnelles et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un système
tellement sclérosé tellement léniniste
qu'il faut avoir un discours clair et
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui mois en le
voyant dans mon entreprise
les accords de branches sont des
contraintes supplémentaires pour les pme
et les tpe
la plupart des cas dans la plupart des
cas les gérer la résultante des
négociations de branches sont déjà des
choses qu'on est l ont déjà été lâché
par les grands groupes et je dirais que
c'est des sommes de contraintes qui
viennent s'accumuler qui aujourd'hui
sont des contraintes qui ne sont plus
tenables par les pme et les tpe
il faut revenir au fond des choses
qu'est ce qui crée de la valeur
c'est pas une branche c'est pas un
secteur d'activité si une entreprise est
aujourd'hui le dialogue social est
censée organiser le travail dont son
entreprise mais branche et d'entreprise
organisé son travail donc organiser les
modalités
j'irai de travail de ses salariés des
salariés les rémunérations est bien à
mettre en adéquation à travers un plan
stratégique à deux trois quatre cinq ans
à travers des objectifs commerciaux à
travers des objectifs industriels à
travers des objectifs d'investissement
qu'est ce que vous voulez mettre des
objectifs d'investissements commerciaux
et industriels dans une branche ça n'a
aucun sens aucun sens donc on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la priorité des priorités
c'est de mettre le maximum girac de la
loque sociale au sein des entreprises
et je suis d'accord avec vous je pense
que tout chef d'entreprise que ce soit
la tp est de 3 personnes voire la pme de
50 cent 100 personnes est tout à fait
capable d'organiser un dialogue social
digne de ce nom dans son entreprise
et ça je pense que c'est vraiment
fondamental parce qu'après il ya une
question de forme
moi je les ai vus dans mon entreprise
pour gérer avoir un dialogue social
abouti le préalable c'est la confiance
et de comprendre avoir conscience qu'on
a un bien commun que l'entreprise
n'appartient ni aux chefs d'entreprise
ni aux salariés
on a bien commun qui s'appelle
l'entreprise et son entreprise en fait
il n'y a plus rien c'est le néant la
branche ça correspond à rien ça parle à
personne n'est qu'on parle de branches
on parle de posture on a des
apparatchiks syndicalistes qui viennent
de nulle part qu'on connaît pas qu'ils
connaissent pas l'entreprise et même
aussi parfois des responsables patronaux
qui pour des intérêts individuels vont
vont parler au niveau de l'intérêt
collectif
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui nos chefs
d'entreprise est tout à fait à même dont
son entreprise de dialoguer avec ses
salariés sur une base d'un compromis
tout simplement pour tirer vers le haut
tirer vers le haut leur bien commun qui
s'appelle l'entreprise et c'est pour ça
que la loi rebsamen par exemple qui
mettait des comités régionaux syndicaux
pour les tpe tv c'est une absurdité la
plus absolue
c'est incroyable qu'on puisse laisser
faire quelque chose comme ça non
couillaud dialogue social dans
l'entreprise
non enfin limiter au maximum gillet
rennes non parce que voir un discours
clair mais limité au maximum conscience
qu'il ya des il ya des contraintes pour
les accords de branche et les accords au
niveau interprofessionnel et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les chefs d'entreprise
sont prêts pour ça pourquoi
parce que moi quand je parle avec des
chefs d'entreprise je pense que le
modèle du chef d'entreprise qui dit oui
on va essayer d'exploiter les salariés
tirer les profits
ça n'a plus aucun sens aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui chef d'entreprise recherche
du sens à sa vie et le sens à sa vie
c'est son entreprise avec ses salariés
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans les
pme tpe mais même dans les groupes
opposés les salariés et les chefs
d'entreprise ça n'a plus aucun sens et
notamment dans la génération ce qu'on
appelle génération y
moi je suis un peu la limite la question
du sens c'est fondamental dire que des
profits pour des profits ça n'a pas de
sens en revanche oui de tirer un bien
commun qui s'appelle l'entreprise
d'avoir une économie au service de
l'homme
ça c'est quelque chose qui met au coeur
des discussions des chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui pour parler des règles les
règles je pense que l'on parlait de
technicité je suis parfaitement d'accord
je pense qu'il faut sortir un peu du dû
prendre un peu d'air je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on sait exactement ce
qu'il faut mettre en place
mais aujourd'hui à la coupe du monde de
rugby et on voit très bien qu'il ya la
règle mais on parle très peu des
arbitres et on sait très bien que c'est
fondamental et moi je vais quand même
aborder un sujet qui qui me semble
important c'est donc les arbitres est un
moment l'inspection du travail
la cession du travail qui sont ces
conseillers qui sont liés certes
adapterons d'après de pardon donc je
disais tout simplement qu'il faut
rénover l'inspection du travail pourquoi
parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui un
soutien du travail n'est plus du tout
dans son rôle il faut juste avoir vécu
moi je vais juste parler juste un
exemple très concret un exe un accident
mortel dans son entreprise dans
l'industrie notamment vous êtes traité
d'assassin et ça je pense que c'est
inacceptable moi l'année dernière j'ai
une instruction d'être une inspectrice
du travail qui m'a expliqué que les rtt
devait être qualifié en temps de travail
effectif
c'est absolument aberrant aberrant donc
on voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'insolent du travail est un bras armé
syndicats qu'il faut revenir rénové aux
profondeurs donc voilà donc je pense que
le message crucial s'il faut retenir
quelque chose c'est mettons le dialogue
social dans les entreprises qui est la
seule entité de création de valeur en
france